music
Thank you for coming to stream, you catch an app after the abduction,
no but I did go for a walk, I did go for a walk after the abduction, I should have caught an app though,
I should have napped instead, I needed one but I felt like I should have, I felt like I needed
exercise so I walked to Wendy's and ate food there, that's my exercise going to the restaurant,
walking to the restaurant. Proud of you, thank you, an app would have been nice but I feel like,
I don't know, I feel like I was more, we call it, when you do activities, when you do things,
what'd you get? I got a Caesar salad and a burger, and a diet coke, that's right, I like diet coke,
I like diet coke, I know people don't like diet, I like diet, I know people are like,
oh diet coke tastes like flat soda, like flat, like old, like it's been sitting out, I like that,
I like that about it, I like the taste of it having been sitting out and not being fizzy anymore,
I like that taste, that tastes good to me, so happy 30k and almost 50k, thank you,
also as you can see in the pinned message on the stream, I did make a new video,
it's with Momosa who now goes by Ruruneru, but I felt like it was more appropriate to tag her as
Momosa just because she doesn't have a YouTube channel as Ruruneru, I couldn't find one, so I
was like, I gotta tag her on YouTube somehow, I tagged her as Momosa but in the description,
you can find her links as Ruruneru, go support her as Ruruneru because she's not really
active as Momosa anymore, I will still love you even during these hard times, what do you mean
hard times, what do you mean hard times, you can't match my freak as I like diet soda,
hmm, distinct taste but I like non-aspartame diets, I don't know, they're all good,
thank you for the five dollars, it was in the plans, I'm not sure if it's still happening,
um, I could help make one because I do have experience like managing a Minecraft server,
but I feel like Porstrani and Manesan are like stretched thin, so if there will be it wouldn't be
very soon I guess, I don't really play Minecraft on stream because I don't know,
I just feel like it's not an entertaining game to play, I don't play many games on stream just
because I don't know, maybe it's just me but like, well I'm not a gamer and and too I just like,
I don't really watch a lot of gaming streams, like the reason I watch a stream is for the person,
so like gaming streams that are like too heavy on gaming, it's like I'm not here to watch you
sit there and play a game, I'm here to like talk to you, I'm here to talk to you, you know,
it is a good app game I guess, I was a little worried too though because I've seen like comments
of people being like oh blank is playing Minecraft again cringe and I was like damn what's wrong
with Minecraft, you prefer Zatsu's, personally as a viewer yes, I do not care for the block game,
see, people don't really care too much about block game, even though it is popular,
no matter what you do I'm here for the cute sister, thank you,
that's why I actually, even though I've done a lot of collabs, I don't actually watch many
collabs as a viewer either because when I'm following a streamer like I'm following you for you,
not to watch you collab with someone else, that sounds mean, but I don't personally like watching
collabs, I tend to stay away from collabs, so even though I collab a lot with people, I collab
a lot with people just to show people like hey, we're not lonely as fuck, we got, we got friends,
you know, like that kata collab was so fun, kata so cute, does she call herself kata, no it's kata
right, I know she's cute, she's fun, I really enjoyed collabing with her, she's really friendly,
as a clipper I honestly prefer zatsu's, yeah, that too, that too,
I like some collabs, but in general I don't really like them either, yeah, I, I understand,
kata was a trip,
would you rather infinite bacon but no games, or infinite games but no games,
what, thank you for the $5, do you mean infinite games but no bacon,
I would rather infinite bacon, of course, of course,
was that a plan or schedule collab that I forgot about or was it gorilla, so
um, I think we decided on like Tuesday or Wednesday that we were gonna have the stream on Friday,
it was very last minute and she didn't put her, she didn't put her stream waiting room up until
this morning, I think, so I felt like, I just didn't, it kind of slipped my mind until like the
day before and I was like, oh shit, I planned to collab with kata, oops, so it was, it was pretty
last minute, yeah, infinite games but no games, I feel like Amy's been asked that before, I feel
like I've been asked that before too, yeah, sounds familiar, um, that was a joke from the youtuber
are you gay? why are you acting so gay?
I don't watch jay schlatt, I've heard of jay schlatt before, I don't even know if I'm pronouncing
the name right, jay schlatt, schlatt, thank you for the $1, I want to know did you ban my main
account blue brawler or was it a shadow ban, do you want me to look up right now if you're banned,
sure, I'll do it, just for you, just for you, but I have personally not banned a lot of people,
if I have to personally ban you myself, you've done some messed up stuff, if I have to go out of
my way to log into my youtube account and manually type your name into the banned chatter section,
then you fucked up, but otherwise, how do I even see that actually, I forgot, I don't do it often,
um, oh here it is community, um, hidden users, oh, um, man, there's like hundreds of people here,
can I control f, oh yeah, yeah, you're banned, uh, I can't tell you why, you'll have to ask a
moderator, actually I don't think you can talk to moderators, please ban me, okay,
okay, I'd use your on this channel, thank you for the ten dollars,
I'm kidding, I'll unban you, I'll unban you, don't ask to be banned, I will ban you,
like don't ask for it, I will do it, I actually forgot, okay here it is,
you guys are weird,
okay, it means a people pleaser, kind of, yeah,
so the guy who was banned is here on an alt, he says, yeah, I mean, I don't know what the reason
was, so I feel like I don't have, because sometimes people get banned for smaller reasons,
for example, if you comment something kind of rude, I'll just ban you sometimes,
like on YouTube videos, if you say like something even remotely rude, I'll just ban you, so you
know, I don't care, watch your mouth, because it could happen again, it could happen any moment,
okay, watch your mouth, don't be mean to my, don't be mean to my little sister,
thank you for the membership, I've been a bad boy, oh, time me out, oh no,
okay, fine, I'll time you out, there you go,
is this what you guys want, easy trigger, sometimes of course, why would I let someone
comment like even remotely rude stuff, you know, is that a new type of masochism, apparently,
apparently, and sometimes people don't know it's rude either, because sometimes people are just
and don't realize that what they're saying is kind of rude, is this stream dumb, yes, chat needs
correction, I'm the emperor, all right, I guess, I guess, if we all have to be banned, I can't ban
you all, I'm not going to ban everyone, I don't have time to ban you and then unban you,
my autism has been a curse in that regard for forever, rude without realizing it, yeah,
but obviously, I don't know what everyone's situation is, so I can't be like, oh, maybe
they have autism and don't realize that they're being rude, no, I slam the hammer,
I don't care, she does as we ask, that's not what I mean,
that's not what I mean, thank you for becoming a member, it's only a shame if light teasing gets
mistaken as bullying, no, I can tell when someone is like lightly teasing, usually, obviously,
things get misinterpreted through text sometimes, because we're all texting, technically, chat is
texting, but yeah, thank you for the $1, oopsies, I keep closing stream elements like an idiot,
keep it opening, congratulations on 30k, very much deserved, thank you, wait a minute,
did I write 20k in my powerpoint?
no, I said 30k, okay, I'll show you my powerpoint now,
you can put two year subscribers chat on or something like that and we'll all be banned,
no, I won't do that, I won't do that, I won't do that, don't worry,
if we break 50k during the 30k celebration, that would be cool, but I don't think we'll make it,
let me see, I think we need like 800 more, I need about 800 more, 850?
850, I don't, I don't think I'll get 850, unless I like post a short right now and it blows up,
like immediately, I believe I'll reach 50k during this stream, but that's okay, I also don't even
have a post, a short to post it right now, do not make 800 bots please, you're gonna get my channel
banned, for botting, do not, thank you, it is time to post the out of out of short, I don't have it,
I don't have it, I sent it to get edited but I didn't get it back yet, all right anyways let me
open the slideshow and go here
okay
let me make that a little smaller, here it is, it means apartment tour, thank you for 30k, yippee
thank you for 30k
I will make 800 real people love you, thank you, you can try, I think it would be better if I
reached that myself, but thank you, not in Minecraft this time actually, this time it's real, this time
it's real life, it unfortunately my real um place looks nothing like the Minecraft place,
unfortunately it looks nothing like that, already gets an A plus for design, oh I just got it off
of, you can literally see the watermark on the side, slidesmania.com, I just got it from slidesmania.com
all right let's get started I guess, um next slide, all right we're gonna start with a little
disclaimer or a side note, when I see apartment tours or room tours from a lot of youtubers
they tend to have really nice places because obviously you know you don't want to do an
apartment tour if your apartment is ugly and um I feel the same way, I'm like maybe I shouldn't
have said I'll do an apartment tour because there's not really anything interesting to see, um
yeah so in no way is this apartment aesthetic or pretty, um please don't have high expectations
okay, don't don't feel like oh she's gonna have like those Sanrio rooms on tiktok
or stuff like that, um I moved out as 17 and have I've had no financial support from my parents
ever since then, so this place kind of looks rough, um it's not a fancy place at all and uh
but it's mine so I like it so show your mouth I don't want to see, I don't want to see any comments
like this place looks ghetto, it is ghetto, it is ghetto, um yeah so and I was a bro college
student until recently okay I did my best with the decor with with what I had which is goodwill
and my mom and well not my mom but like my mom's old furniture and amazon.com and sometimes when
my mom comes over like um like what's it called furniture stores we usually know
now you're just broke shut damn you live like this yeah also I was raised by a hoarder mom
okay and my hoarder mom was raised by a hoarder grandma so I'm a little bit of a hoarder too
so if so if you think like wow this place is kind of cluttered it's because I'm a little
bit of a hoarder okay I'm a little I have more than enough Tupperware and most of it does not match
and most of it does not match yes generational hoarding it's it's it's it's definitely busy I'll
just say that it's it's definitely a busy apartment we don't do minimalism around here okay we we
we do not do minimalism I'm working on it it's um it's definitely I mean it's so bad but it's
I guess not as bad as it could be maybe rat room probably more interesting than Amy's room you
think I have a separate room for my rats I mean I'd love to one day have a rat room but no my rats
live with me in my room you live like a real person I mean I I guess an average I don't even know
if it's average thank you for the uh thank you for the membership yeah the rat room is my room
does this mean I can burrow into a corner of your room and eat scraps and pet your rats yeah
if you want to if you if you want to do that sure embrace minimalism no reject minimalism
become a hoarder like me become a hoarder are the rats presentable no the rats are never presentable
the rats the rats get the bed when they want to get the bed okay okay sorry I'm like stalling
because I'm like nervous um are you gay why are you acting so gay Raven chipped six dollars and
90 cents Amy's a hoarder more like a order of orange heart wait more like an odd dev
wait I'm gonna be real I don't know what that means hold on
odd dev I kind of forgot what that means
I don't even know if I'm pronouncing it right
you mean like a snack an appetizer oh it's french for appetizer oh
okay okay okay okay okay I see I see I see you know a bit of french I do know french but I
don't know everything in french I don't know everything okay I'm the main course thank you
for calling me a snack I should put my stream elements on a different page okay um go back
to the slideshow right um so here's the table of contents first we'll go over my bedroom
and then we'll go over the rat cage which is in my bedroom and then we'll go over my bathroom
and then we'll go over my hallway question mark I put a question mark because I can't really consider
it a hallway because there there's not much hallway you know but I call it the hallway so it's the
hallway Amy's a three course meal she's got everything you can need and she'll fill you up
real good online did you clean before taking the photos a little bit it's still it's still messy
and like cluttered um but it's not the worst it can be let's just say that
let's just say that um number five my living room and number six my kitchen which is kind
of the same as my living room because they're connected all right um I'm nervous why am I nervous
I feel like people are gonna judge me oh shit I forgot I wanted to turn my um I wanted to turn
my stream not the quality but the bit rate I guess the bit rate is kind of like the quality
thank you for the two dollars speaking of snacks bam honey bun thank you thank you one second let me
check something I'm watching an ad okay
this is just me or a stream kind of blurry I think it's because I put my bit rate too high
I need to lower my bit rate
whatever sorry I'm like really picky about stream quality okay sorry moving on moving on me
won't moving on get you block get you block for me I smell that smell or snack that smell
doesn't look blurry I nitpick I nitpick you got ads in your presentation though I got ads on my
own stream okay are you ready for my bedroom okay here we go number one my bedroom oh I'm nervous
I'm nervous okay okay okay mods be on alert be on alert all right here's my bedroom it's very
cluttered like I said before there's a lot of clutter um I like to have cute stuff in my room
so yeah I've just I just have a lot of cute stuff I got a lot of squishmallows I have a lot of um
I don't know can you see my mouse oh yeah you can this is my ac right here I feel like my mouse is
kind of small is your pointer laser pointer fuck yeah okay this is my ac right here a lot of people
are like oh get an ac in me if you're so hot bitch this is my ac um it's it there's not a lot of
space here for anything but this is where my ac is this is my piano over here this is my little
piano chair um what up this is the rat cage obviously less clutter than mine that's good
that's good how long is that Pikachu my aunt my aunt gave me that Pikachu when I visited her
she's very nice she always gives me well one of my aunts I have a lot of aunts um
but she always gives me like me and my mom like really nice gifts whenever we go and visit her
so she's really nice what is that poster Pikachu oh this one says ho and a easy
ho and a easy
needs more plushies I know I'm getting there I'm getting there um there's more um what's it called
there's more posters here but I didn't really take pictures of them
how many times have you been buried in plushie of avalanche none this keeps them all together up here
and then these are usually like used to sleep bro I need like five plushies to sleep
the the net has never fallen the net has never fallen um this is more plushies and like storage
this is a clock that I never used but I have it because it's cute this is more storage this is
storage here uh these are just cute little figures this is like my underwear plus art drawer um
this is the rat cage this is I kind of sometimes use this whiteboard to like write down stuff I
need to do this is some art that I was gifted by a friend as you can tell and this so I have
those tiktok led lights right and they actually used to go like past here throughout the whole
ceiling um I have them down here on my bed oh hold on I have them down here um why the ac
instead of a window unit because my windows are like they open they open like across um
so there are like zero window units that fit in windows that open like across like that instead of
up and down um window units window ac units um are made for windows that open like top to bottom
if that makes sense I really don't know how to explain it but my windows open side to side
does that make sense so I need to have this instead the pile of plushies ominously hanging
over the bed they could fall down at any moment I thank you for the five dollars yeah it makes
sense yeah yeah horizontal they've never fallen before I even had the the polar bear up here at
one point um and it has not fallen on me they open like a door um no a door opens like outwards
slash inwards this just opens side to side like a like a sliding glass door kind of like that yeah
so yeah um yeah it slides horizontally rather than vertically all of my windows do that so
there is no window I can put an ac unit on um I have my iPad on the bed I think these are
hair clips I'm not sure what those are um I think that's everything here on this side
very interesting very cool um yeah right there's the other side of my room this is my ethernet
cord that connects to my um pc I do use ethernet to stream um and I have to put it um up on the
ceiling because otherwise the rats will chew on it yeah they'll chew on it so I have to put it on
the ceiling obviously this is where I'm sitting right now literally I'm sitting right here right
now um but yeah these this this this this was what the whole room looked like with all the lights
but my rats actually chewed on the other side like the lights on the other side of the room so um
yeah um it doesn't work anymore I need to get I need to get more lights for the other side of the room
you can put an ac unit in the sliding window you just need to use a couple extra parts to make
sure it doesn't jank yeah I I've considered it but I just feel like it's too much work and it's no
different than the one I'm using right now like I'll it I don't know how to explain it like it's
still gonna be loud and noisy and annoying and it's gonna be really really annoying to take
out of the window when it's winter so yeah they were on the ceiling no I'm saying I can't I can't
put this wire anywhere but the ceiling because the rats will chew on it um this is the sweater that
a lot of people liked because you can see my boobas through it um I have posters on the wall like
the the Hello Kitty and and Hatsune Miku the monitor on the right looks smaller than your keyboard
it is a smaller monitor but it's not smaller than my keyboard but it is a smaller monitor
you don't need to take a window ac unit out during the winter but you'll hear outside
how am I supposed to record if you can hear outside I record ASMR like the the 3DO is super
super sensitive the 3DO literally hears my rats sneeze like the 3DO hears footsteps from downstairs
like the 3DO hears everything I can't keep my window open they need to be closed so I would
need to take the ac unit out all the time it's a good sweater I'm glad you like that sweater
um I don't know what else this is about the calendar um yeah that was about it
is that sound perfect stuff on the walls it sure is I don't know if it helps but I use it anyways
because it's fancy rats sneeze ASMR they they don't sneeze that often yeah the 3DO can literally
hear your thoughts it means like someone would be walking on the street and screaming the address
for no reasons honestly honestly the 3DO hears everything so I I cannot do anything with the
with the window open I'm not selling that sweater I like that sweater I have two pairs of headphones
this one is a bluetooth headphone for just casual and then this one is the headphones I actually use
to like record ASMR it's like a really technical technical like fancy pair of headphones um and
it's really sound proofy and I don't know I I think they're good headphones they they make
everything sound really good so yeah you your room is such a stereotypical girly room thank you
I'm actually happy to to hear that and not and not see like comments like wow your room is kind
of cluttered and dirty looking also the rats chewed on my um door here so yeah also the
the floor is dirty because I'm a dirty person that's why the floor is dirty I don't know what else
there is um they don't want to say I have a bunch of bags a solid rat room out of 10
dang girl you live like this
you acted like it was bad it's super normal and girly the bedroom is probably the cutest
room in the place the rest is kind of meh yeah
is your pc on the carpeted floor uh I have this um oh maybe a little bit yeah maybe like half
but I have this like desk like map floor map I want to see the fridge I'll show you my fridge
I'll show you my fridge okay next so I wanted to take a picture of this specifically because this
is my this is my wire organization what's it called my wire management this is my wire
almost everything is covered in wire protectors because the rats will chew on everything the
only thing that's not covered in wire protectors is this pink wire because that's for my mouse and
the wire protector um weighs down my mouse a lot so it becomes really difficult to use but everything
else is basically covered in wire protectors cable management yeah this is my cable management
hardly the worst I've seen that's good I feel like it doesn't look that bad because all of the
wires are like different colors and it makes it look a little bit cleaner it hurts
can't you get a wireless mouse I can't my computer just doesn't really work with bluetooth
I have the option to use bluetooth it will connect but it will not work well it will it
will be very very laggy and disconnect all the time and cut out all the time I don't know what's
wrong with my pc so I have to use wires for everything I have to use wires for my keyboard
for my mouse for my headphones for everything um so yeah um my wireless mice have dongles
yeah but like it doesn't work it just doesn't work not even with anything I don't know why
I don't know what's wrong with my pc like like it connects like they they connect to each other um
and they they do kind of work sort of I don't know what's wrong like it'll work with like the the
bluetooth stuff I use will work with everything it will work with my laptop with my phone um
with my ipad like it'll work with everything except for my pc I don't know what the problem is
um so I just use wired stuff yeah probably because it has to go through the desk
maybe I don't really know I will not put a new pc on throne no no no no no no I
my pc's okay the way it is don't feel don't feel uh don't feel pressure to get me a new pc
um yes you will see the inside of my fridge
all right so that's my wire management next is the rat cage
um no don't spoil me don't spoil me don't spoil me wired stuff is fine wired stuff is fine it worked
fine I just sometimes have to replace the wires because the rats will chew on it
all right this is my rat cage um it doesn't need cleaning it is it is time to be cleaned um but
you have to remember that these are rats okay these are like trash animals they're the equivalent
of like raccoons um they will do everything they possibly can to make a mess out of their cage
like the next day after you clean it so it's dirty it's really dirty
if your motherboard has bluetooth built-in and you're using an adapter you have to disable
one or the other bro I don't know I don't know anything about PCs I I will I am okay with my
wires do not buy me a new pc living better than me I mean it's just a cage this is a very very
standard oh why are you acting so gay rollin legend 99 underscore tipped $5 pc fund no do not
do not send pc money but thank you for the five dollars um this is only the top part of the cage
but this is a very standard cage for a rats um I don't know this is one of them in here I think
they all usually like to sleep in one of these pods here but sometimes they'll sleep here
but anytime I put blankets anywhere they will just move the blankets like these two blankets
used to be on either side of this but they just move the blankets all the time so yeah
and then this is the bottom of their cage it's a lot more empty than the top
um because you can tell that they've been trying to chew on this wire but it has the
wire protector on it's a lot more empty than the top of the cage because um they have mites or they
recently um had mites so I had to strip the cage and remove anything that couldn't be cleaned
and replace it with new stuff so I haven't completely finished like replacing um the new
stuff in here so yeah um this is the lower part and then this is the top part of the rat cage
pc fund stuff giving me a pc fund my pc is fine as it is if anything give me like
better internet fund canadian internet is so expensive and so bad and so slow so yeah
where's the mess am I blind it's a messy cage it's nowhere near a clean rat cage um but that's
because they're rats so yeah they just they're rats they will live are you okay why are you acting so
okay thank you for the 420 wants to buy more cables based cables enjoy are you a rat
rats love cables two-story apartment damn the rats are living nice the rats are not living
nice the rats are living as they should be living they this is a standard rat cage I think you guys
have a skewed perception of how rats should live rat just all right next place all right I've never
seen a rat cage this big well then you've seen bad rat cages you've seen bad rat cages this is a
very standard normal average rat cage um yeah this is my bathroom um it's very small um
and it's very dimly lit I don't know why it's dimly lit but this is my this is my bathroom
that's not my bathroom all right this is my bathroom so um it's pretty tiny um I don't know
it's it's a lot better than it used to look I didn't have the funds to furnish my apartment until
like a year ago so a year ago was really bad in my entire place was really bad a year ago I should
show you pictures but I'm not going to because that's embarrassing but um it's a lot better than
than it was before um but this is my grandma energy I know I also have a hello kitty plus right here
but I kind of like grandma stuff I'm kind of a grandma the light is so dim I know a lot of
my apartment lights are very very dim um because they're going out I think so yeah this is my shower
slash bathtub this is where I put all the dirty laundry this is my tiny tiny washing machine um
this is where I put some random bullshit and more bullshit I'm a hoarder I have a lot of bullshit
I got a tiny cute trash can though and then wash your hands and brush your teeth signs because I
forget a lot yes the hello kitty plushie is the comfort plushie for when I'm pooping
washing machine and bathroom huh interesting well I I don't have a laundry room so um
I can't really put it anywhere else so yeah
yes I need you to change my light bulbs did you furnish the rat cage before your own furniture
I mean it's a rat cage there's not much to furnish it's just a rat cage does the talus a boo it does
it does hag we're hag maxing in the bathroom
no there's no bathroom ASMR what am I supposed to do shit and piss and fart is that the bathroom ASMR you want
so I don't have a dryer just because I I there's no like tiny dryers like this from
what I know of yes you want that ASMR okay okay okay okay okay
okay no I'm not doing that
okay um yeah that's not much this is the fan for when the poop is really bad I'm standing in my
bathtub right now so I could really get the scope I don't this is the heater I I don't know why there's
a heater in my bathroom but this is the bathroom heater I really I don't know why there's a heater
in the bathroom um but there is and I didn't even I didn't know this was a heater until like
very very recently because I looked at it one day and I was like wait why is there a knob here
and there's a knob there because you can change the heat level in the bathroom you can heat up the
bathroom and so I was like what the fuck and apparently the whole time I've been living here
I've had the bathroom heated uh at like medium level and I was like what the fuck the bathroom's
just been constantly heated you don't want to poop in the cold trust me I guess but still yeah
that's why there's a heater I mean the my my apartment stays generally pretty hot even without
the heater but yeah uh cold toilet seats I guess
yeah it's just something about warm stinky bathroom all right uh it's about it I don't know
I got a listerine I got skincare I got a razor I got fake plants
um that's about it for the bathroom there you're gonna see this is gonna be a very short
apartment tour because there's not much to show you um oops okay now it's the the hallway
question mark go through all of your makeup cabinet I don't have a makeup cabinet hold on
my makeup is all here all the way up here that's all the makeup I have all right here's the hallway
um it's kind of a hallway it leads into my windowless moisture must be bad the moisture is
awful I get mold in there all the time I have to like clean the ceiling like every two weeks
because it just accumulates so much mold um anyways it does get very hot in Canada people
are always like oh my god Canada is so cold you guys got polar bears and uh it glues like no
no we get very hot sometimes yeah this is my um hallway I got a mirror here with some vines
and some more fake plants this bag is just for holding my camera this is like a photo album
this is like my um agenda is that what it's called how tall is the mirror it's short it's a short
mirror I I I can't like it looks like like you could hang it but I I don't have the facilities
to hang the mirror so it's just kind of sitting there um eighth of a hallway yeah it's not really
a hallway the mirror is shorter than me yes the mirror is shorter than me um I have an agenda
where I try to plan shit but I always fail um this is like kitchen stuff and also my toothbrush
because I don't like to keep my toothbrush in my bathroom so yeah looks looks like my
hallway but wider and less cluttered really this is a very not wide hallway this is a very
not wide hallway at all but if you think it's wide that's good that's good this is a hallway okay
this is a hallway and it leads into my kitchen over here and my living room over here and this is like
my um what's it called shoe box shoe box no toothbrush in the bathroom no I piss and
shit in that bathroom I don't want to keep my toothbrush in there I piss and shit in there
so yeah I don't want poop particles to get on my toothbrush shirek I guess I have shoes in here
and then in here too I have shoes and there's a sweater and umbrella and keys and stuff
oh it might be a small apartment but it has in me in it so it's worth everything oh it's so
cute you don't use a toothbrush case no I'm lazy I'm gonna have to clean the toothbrush case
oops all right now we have the living room now we got the living room ready okay it's very
cluttered it it's it's very very cluttered I'll I'll admit and it's got a lot of shit in it um
so let's let's go over this I guess all of this uh stuff on the wall is uh from Goodwill
this is a random AI generated tapestry I didn't know it was AI generated until it arrived at
my front door from Amazon and I was like oh fuck that's AI generated oh wow yo this place is huge
it looks very big I'll admit it definitely looks big but I wish I could take a picture of me in
it because it's very small um it's a very small apartment so but it does look pretty big
I'm standing in the kitchen taking this by the way I am this this little area here is the start
of the kitchen and this is the wire for my wi-fi my I keep my wi-fi stuff in my room
from Goodwill and no Jesus pictures why would I have Jesus in my
why would I have Jesus in my living room I think you'll be shocked at how normal your apartment
looks when you do a rate the pinpals room I should do that I should do a rate the pinpals room
I'm gonna do that or like rate your apartment yeah they sell AI generated tapestries on Amazon I
don't know why doesn't look that cluttered to me that's good my mom thinks it's very very cluttered
which is saying a lot for her because her place is awfully cluttered like way way way way more
cluttered than me but yeah is it is weird to see full carpet everywhere well the landlord
the landlord wanted carpet so we got carpet um where do I start okay okay um over here is my
tarantula uh tank I will show you that as well this is just a random squishmallow I sleep here on
this couch it it um extends into a uh couch bed I got this couch very recently before this couch
I had the couch that my mom gave me when I moved out um she got it from her ex boyfriend and she
kept it in her basement for like 10 years until she gave it to me and um a funny story about that
actually because one day I saw a little mouse like running across my living room or something and I was
like fuck I have a mouse oh no actually the the the history of of the mouse was I was taking out my
trash the couch does look big it's a pretty it's a decently big couch but I was taking out my
trash one day and there was a mouse like on top of my trash and it like jumped out and it ran around
my kitchen and finally I like it it hid somewhere and I was like fuck now I have a mouse in my apartment
I mean it was always there but at least it was contained into my cupboards where my trash is
but now it's just in my apartment everywhere um and so I couldn't I couldn't hold on I need water
I couldn't find um where it was for for like a really long time I couldn't find where it was hiding
but just randomly I would see the mouse in my apartment in the bathroom I would see it run
like run around I would see it like run into my closet like I would just randomly see the mouse um
until finally um I was I was I had finally gotten this new couch right so I was taking out my old
couch and as I was taking don't rats eat mice not I mean I don't think they really ever interacted
I think the mouse is smart enough not to go near the rats um you ignored the problem until it got
worse huh no no no it never really got worse um I didn't want to kill it and I I was too broke
this is really sad I was too broke to afford the um the humane mice traps that you could buy online
so I just let it be I was too broke to afford the mice trap so I was like you know what I'm just
gonna live with this mouse until the day that I was taking out my old couch I noticed that there was
like stuffing falling out of the couch as I was taking it outside and I was like that's weird I
mean it's an old couch so whatever that's weird rose and then food starting started falling out of
the couch food egg shells like bread crumbs like bread bread bunches started falling out of the couch
and I was like oh my god the mouse lived in my couch and I'm guessing the mouse is still in my couch
probably in some like um trash yard because I I asked a trash service to pick up my old couch
but I think the mouse lived in my couch and probably died in my couch and I was sleeping
and sitting on that couch literally monster under the bed
so um yeah it's most likely dead now um because I had gone a really long time without seeing it
anymore so I'm guessing it died in my couch and that's why I never found its dead body because it
died in my couch and um very happy I took that couch out because otherwise I would still have a
dead mouse in my couch um anyways um now I have a new couch and I don't think there's any mice in it
because I've never seen a mouse in my apartment since um it was just a lot of I got I got a pumpkin
pillow um I'm hopefully the I'm hopefully I'm hoping to get another pumpkin pillow because I used to
have two one orange and one green one but the orange one fell apart because it was really
shittily made um so I'm hoping once the Halloween season hits I can go to like marshals or or
winners or home cents and like find it a cute new pumpkin cat uh pumpkin pillows because they're really
cute um I feel like a dead mouse would produce quite a lot of smell you'd know if it was in there I
feel like it wouldn't though also there's smells in my apartment okay there's there's there's lots
of smells I'm not a clean person let's just say that um yeah um I put there's storage under this
couch too which is helpful I put a lot of bullshit under there this is the heater I cover it because
it's ugly but this is the heater during the winter um Canadian apartments um or at least where I live
are not legally required to have air conditioning but they are legally acquired to
required to have heating so luckily I have heating if it wasn't legally required my landlord probably
wouldn't put it in but it is legally acquired so luckily I don't I don't um I don't freeze to death
every winter uh what else so this couch is actually um this couch was actually the couch I had bought
to replace my old couch right after I had um kicked it out of my apartment um and then when I got it
I was like oh that's why it was so cheap because it's tiny and uncomfortable and like rock solid
and like mega thin so um I I didn't want to get rid of it when I actually was able to like afford a
new couch that's like actually squishy and comfy and big um because I'm a hoarder so I was like well
I guess it's gonna just sit there for now um yeah it's a really tiny couch and it's really hard
and it's really thin and I hate it but yeah you get what you pay for um
there was once a mouse that was dead so long and my pantry it shuffled up before we found it we
would have found it faster if it smelled that bad yeah like I don't know sometimes sometimes
things don't smell that bad what's in the drawer tower I don't show you what's in it but um this
one has just like random shit I don't know like tech stuff this one has um like winter stuff
I don't be honest I don't even know what's in here I think this is like old binders from school
I don't know what's in here I think no I don't know what's in here I need to go look I don't remember
um and here's like witchcraft stuff this is my um witchcraft altar where I do witchcraft
um
this is like a bookshelf there's on the bottom three levels also I cannot move these bookshelves
if I ever leave this apartment these bookshelves are gonna have to stay here because if I move
these bookshelves they will fall apart because I built them so if I built them they will fall apart
if I touch them too much like this one especially if I touch this one it falls apart so yeah um
but there's like stuff here like a little dragon egg um this lamp that I don't use but I keep
anyways because I'm a hoarder um there's like wrap blankets there's rat stuff here rat stuff here
rat stuff here and some wrap blankets up here some binders I don't know nothing really interesting
uh I have like I have a Nintendo Wii and recently like a switch like a actual switch that connects
to the computer uh there's a lot of storage I need I need a lot of storage like because I have so
much shit because I'm a hoarder like storage is here storage is here storage is here storage is
here storage is inside the table as well storage is inside of the um inside of the couch obviously
this is all storage this is all storage for more witchcraft stuff um there's a table you can't
really see it but there's a table right here that is also storage for a bunch of bullshit um in the
hallway this is all storage for a bunch of bullshit like I just have too much stuff and
luckily um this isn't hoarder tier I just have a lot of things if I if I opened these you would see
how full they all are but it because they're all in storage you don't see them if that makes sense
um so yeah is there storage in the tv unfortunately not oops I'm going backwards um but yeah
yeah I think that's all that is that's there um we'll go more in depth these are the paintings
very nice very nice um I painted this one black it was originally gold but I painted it black it's
fake obviously these are some kitty cats I printed this out myself and glued it together in fours
these are more kitty cats this is just some random books this is a um a mirror my mom gave me
because she gives me a lot of random shit and she gets offended if I throw them away so I have to
keep it for how much stuff you have you have it all stored away very nicely yes only recently
it used to just be sitting out like on the floor only recently I have since been able to get
storage for it honestly your apartment is fine it looks cozy thank you thank you I'm glad you like
it um this is like a dragon head that was gifted to me when I was like fucking 14 and I was never
able to hang it everywhere because it was broken um so I kept it in my room at home until I moved
out and my mom obviously gave it to me because she's like this is yours take it so um it may be
hoarder but it's very well organized hoarding mm-hmm mm-hmm they aren't straight no they're not
straight they're not straight at all you're very correct I can't make them straight they're all
tilted I'm aware I I'm not at they're not very well secured let's just say that um anyways this
is the least well secured one in fact this one's being held up by yarn this one's being hung up by
yarn and hot glue so um yeah this is not secure or straight and it's very heavy too but luckily if
it falls it'll just fall on the couch um hopefully no one's on that couch while it falls though
mm-hmm yeah and a lot of hope and trust yep um this is my altar um I have more witchcraft stuff
in here more witchcraft stuff in here these are crystals they're all crystals I think this is
just a little spelled um spell bag this is just cute little decor I don't know um I'm drying out
some flowers currently on the mirror I just air dry them because sometimes I press them in books
but I'm really lazy so lately I've just been air drying my flowers I was expecting the damn
sis you live like this and all I got was a nice apartment massage sorry my lip balm fell on the
floor I was expecting rat nest I'm sorry I'm sorry um tarot deck spotted yes I have I only have two
tarot decks but yes I do have tarot decks any incense uh the incense is here this is the
incense holder I tend to not use that much incense just because um my uh I have a bunch of incense
incense in here but my like rats have very very sensitive um respiratory systems so I
do my best to not really use it that much but I still have it incense incense there are holes
with plugs things everywhere in my permit from last oh yes I have lots of holes in my walls
yes
which decks do you have I just have the like the regular one the something rider
I forgot the name the regular one the regular one we also have incest yes it can stay in the
wall if you use it a lot too I had didn't know um I don't know uh how should I there's like a bunch
of herbs in here there's a bunch of herbs in here these have a bunch of tiny little cute shaped
jars um this says bat wings I can't zoom in can I zoom in oh that's my
I can't really zoom in but this says bat wings but it's just a bunch of tiny like
little bags like this for spells any chance for a member's tarot reading stream eventually
eventually um this is just a random candle that's there because it looks cute this is a bunch of
pens and markers I have a wand in here but I never use it um this is like a little bowl this is more
herbs I think this is jasmine this has a bunch of um essential oils in it which I don't I don't
burn essential oils but I do sometimes use them in spells um I think these two are full of moon
water I think this one's literally just empty I just have it because it looks cute these are a
bunch of little tiny crystals I think these are flowers and and shells um I have a little book
in there that I keep track of spells I have um uh I have another journal where I press flowers in
I like to collect flowers during the the summer um my flower jar is somewhere in the back underneath
here but yeah uh this is just a calendar for stuff it's really cute and I have like some
wax down here and like extra candles stuff like that do you touch grass no
no I don't I don't I don't touch grass
those metal work or wood on the wall um
they're all wood this is wood and this is wood yeah you keep a jar of dead flowers
I keep multiple jars of dead flowers well not dead but dried dried dried flowers
the only problem with um witchcraft streams is I can't do it here I can't bring my set up here
I'd have to bring all my shit to the bedroom and that's annoying maybe one day I'll get a long
enough cord to do a witchcraft stream like right here um why dry flowers
shut I don't I don't have I mean I guess I have fresh flowers outside but I prefer dry flowers
yeah anyways uh next this is my swider uh cage I guess it's uh it's just a five-gallon tank with
like um a mesh top I guess mesh maybe I don't know if mesh is the right word but um
um when did you get into witchcraft like two years ago yeah
this is for streams no I do this in my I do witchcraft in my spare time too um
there's just a bunch of tiny holes on on the on the top so that she can breathe
this is her little water dish there's a bunch of moss and dirt in here and this is her right here
um I believe she is I believe don't I might be wrong
you can't really see her very well but I believe she's a female um
oh fuck Arizona blonde I believe I believe she's a female Arizona blonde um when I bought her
the like there was the option her name is Rango her name is Rango um when I bought her uh
like you have they had the option of like do you want a male baby or a female baby spider
um or for even cheaper do you want a mystery gender because I think they're too young at some
point like they're too young to uh tell what gender they are and I was like fuck yeah give me
a mystery one so I got this one and I think she turned out to be a girl but I'm not entirely sure
but I think so um yeah she's very cute she's a little bit skinny um because I thought she was
like really really fat but so I didn't feed her as much and then she molted and I was like wait
fuck you're actually really skinny sorry males don't live very long males live like 10 years
and then females live like 40 so I'm hoping she'll really be with me for a long time she's kind of
aggressive um yes she wears little spider makeup and skirts she's a little bit aggressive she um
she's about five years old maybe maybe five speaking as a brujo if you do a witchcraft stream
you have to be prepared for people joining just to proselytize at you what's proselytize mean
I don't know what that word means hold on let me look that up
the action of attempting to convert someone from one religion belief or opinion to another oh
I mean that's fine it'll probably be a member stream so if you try to do that as a member
you're risking your membership yeah I'm not I'm not like the the the I don't know how to explain it
I'm not like too insane when it comes to witchcraft like I'm not like oh the spirits are talking to me
oh the devil satan satan is leaving me hints in my house that I'm I don't know that I'm
spiritually gifted no like I I'm I'm I'm pretty casual about it um there's not really much to
convert to like you're you're not gonna be like oh my god Amy's insane she needs Jesus
so yeah um yeah hail Santa
um yeah it's pretty much it I think she's five years old maybe a little younger maybe like four
years old um uh I miss having pet insects but my roommates are prises and won't let me buy any
well who cares what's going on Amy thank you for the $1.99 I'm just doing an apartment tour
I might have to go pee real quick but nature literally anything really relating to religion
sadly live and let it live yeah I don't know I'm not here to convert you and you're not here to
convert me so yeah uh yeah this is it she goes in her little hut here they like to burrow so
there's probably like a really big hole in here I'm guessing but I don't bother her um she doesn't
like to be touched so I don't touch her um I will never do like a tarantula stream where I show you
her anything she she will probably bite me or like run away from me and escape under my bed or
something so we're not going to touch her but she is very fluffy and she's very cute um so yeah
uh oops all right wait I'm going backwards wait oh
oh I didn't do the kitchen okay um I'm gonna be right back I'm gonna go pee I'm not going to show
you a picture of my toilet but I'll be right back so one second
um
Okay, now to the kitchen and this is where I did actually bring my phone to piss. Yeah, I can't piss without my phone
Anyways, this is where you'll see my
My fridge
Right, this is my kitchen. Um, I do live like a grandma. I know it's it I live like a grandma
Um, all these photos are like flipped
Because I don't want you to see them
Where's the piano in my bedroom?
There are pictures of like me my mom my friends my family like
Yeah
This is an air fryer, that's right, I own an air fryer
I own an air fryer. This is a toaster. This is the microwave. There's like some cute little at this
These are literally empty. I literally just bought these cuz they're cute
So, yeah, this is the microwave. This is the rice cooker. This is a
empty dirty
clear Tim Horton's cup for emptying my AC because it makes water
This is a cup I drink coffee out of and all there's some sponges up here and down here
There's a GamerSup's cup
This little monkey thing is where I hang bananas on the very rare occasion that I hang bananas
It's very dark in here because these are the only two lights in the kitchen that work. Um, the light up here just doesn't work
So, yeah
I know this is the very very old
Oven it looks old, right? It looks old
What's with the floor? I don't what's with the floor? It's just a floor. I
Didn't I didn't choose anything in this apartment. Yeah, the stove is very very old
It came with this apartment. Obviously, I'm not going to purchase a new stove for my landlord
So the oven doesn't actually work only these stove tops work
And these are just cute little b-bots and bibbits and bobbits
Because they're cute. I just got them because they're cute. Some of them I painted myself like they came ugly painted and I painted them myself
Thank you for becoming a member
The floor is made out of floor. Yeah
The oven doesn't work in your landlord has replaced it
I don't want to bother him because if he comes inside of my apartment and sees the rats
I don't think he will be happy
So I don't bother him and he doesn't bother me. We don't bother each other. He can you know, we don't we don't talk to each other
Yeah
He doesn't need to he doesn't need to come inside. Yes, I need to come inside
Yes, we have a very hands-off relationship. I I pay rent on time and he doesn't he doesn't bother me. So yeah
Yeah
So, yeah
I know there's some pans in here that are most definitely dirty
Also, this this stays open all the time because it just doesn't close
I don't know what happened to it. This is where I keep my garbage and my recycle and also outside, too
This is where I actually put the polar bear
I hit it because my mom comes over and I don't want her to be like, oh, this is a new stuffy. What is this?
You know
I'm just only your landlord into the your bedroom. He doesn't need to go there to replace. I know but I just I don't want to risk it
Okay, I don't want to risk it
Um, I don't know what else is there. This is full of dishes, but you can't actually see them because they're not high enough
So, yeah, is it is it like a terrarium only pets apartment?
Um, it's like a no pets apartment, but they can't legally enforce that so I'm not gonna be like by the way
I have pets
Because you don't need to know. I'm not even supposed to have an air conditioner
You think I want to say that anything? No. Anyways, um
This is my fridge fridge door fridge door, haha fridge door. Okay, so
Tactical camera angle. Why is it tactical? Such a rebel
It looks even worse doesn't look bad. Oh, no, it looks bad. Oh
No, isn't really that bad
Where's the milk? It's literally right in here in Canada. We have bagged milk and then there's more milk down here
Or the vegetables are supposed to be
It is messy, I know, okay
Is it that bad? Oh my god, I didn't know that the fridge was that bad
Okay, okay, we'll go through it. So up here is
lemon juice
rat
rat medicine and ketchup packets
like restaurant sauce
This is Caesar salad sauce, this is inshir, this is baby food
This is for the rats the inshir and the baby food is for the rats. I think this is a mustard
This is like the loop loop loop things
Um, I put them in the fridge because you're supposed to put them in the fridge. I don't know
Um
This is like bulldox spicy sauce, this is mayo ratchas is soy sauce. This is um
What's it called?
something flakes
Bonito flakes. I don't know. There's some kind of some kind of flakes. Um
There is shit to rate it and I know I know I think this is like
Teriyaki sauce
This is some kind of alcohol peach drink that I never finished my mom gave it to me and I never liked it
These this same like breakfast lunch and dinner from the previous tenant and I just never removed them
Um
You're supposed to use them put them in the fridge if you use them on the face if you yeah
But I have nowhere else to put it so I just leave it there
This is one two three bottles of Irish cream
Yeah, lots of condiments I know
Half empty cup of gamer subs with only water in it. Um milk water more sauces down here
I'm gonna be honest. I don't know what this can is back here. It's just a lot of
I think there's some clementines in here too
This is more what we expect. Oh my god, I didn't know my fridge was the worst part. Is it really that bad?
Don't look at the pepper that's been there for like four years
This is like cheese, what's it called parmesan? This is more cheese. This is the rice cooker pot and it's filled with rice
What's the clear blue thing in the door?
This this is the this is the face thing. He's the face rollers
No fruits or vegetables actually
These are eggs, there's some like cottage cheese back here. That's and I think that's I can't believe it's not better
No, those have been back there for like a year at that point probably there's some sesame bread
Up here. Yeah, this is from today. Okay, this is from today. That's not that bad
This is from today. Literally. It's not that bad. I literally like literally right before scream
I just put this cup in there because I went to Wendy's today
Um, there's some spinach back here with some cheese. I think a
What's it called Chinese?
Like those cookies fortune cookies gotta clean that out. I know I do
Right in the fridge is kind of weird. Well, it gets so hot during the summer
I feel like the bread is gonna get moldy if I don't put in the fridge
You know, is it not gonna get moldy like it gets
Like my kitchen goes up to like really really hot
So I put it in the fridge
Why do you have a fortune cookie in there cuz I ordered Chinese food and I didn't finish the fortune cookie
Damp is worse for bread than heat. Is it I don't know. I noticed it. It helps
Does help it last longer, okay, there we go
Well, doesn't heat cause moisture anyways, um, I got samosas I have vanilla
Yogurt, I only like vanilla yogurt. Okay. Um, I
have
I
Was I ordered uber eats and I ordered Chick-fil-A and I wanted the Chick-fil-A sauce
But this is the only option they had for Chick-fil-A sauce
So I just got a little bottle of Chick-fil-A sauce and honestly, it's really good
My fridge just mostly has sauces. Um, yeah, there's some monster back there. I
Think that's pretty much it up here. These are two trays of ice. This is the ice dildo. These are like really old pierogies
This is a
Pepper
This is ice from the previous
Where's your food I'm asking myself the same question
Thank you for the five dollars
I mean, I just want to let you know that strong is ready to wrestle with any veeler in every ring
Especially you just a fair warning. Oh, I think I could beat strannia. She seems really weak
These are breakfast sausages, I think these are more samosas something like that and these are pot stickers
And yeah, that's my fridge
Get the last tenet shit out of there. No
I'm lazy. It's just ice like it's literally just ice
There's not much else in here. I think that's about it
Yeah
This is hoarder in full view. It's literally just sauces
How is it where it's just very like messy, but it's just mostly sauces
There's some like salami up here. I
I
Don't know what to tell you
I'm the sauce boss. No, they're not expired. No, I literally just got this new sriracha today. No, so these are not expired. I
Use my sauces. I'm a saucy girl. I use all my sauces
Like I'm sorry. I like to dip my food in sauces. I like I like sauces. I
Don't know like I use this sauce. I use all of these sauces
I don't think there's a single sauce in here that I don't use I use all my sauces
Yeah
Sources on what well not specifically on stuff, but like teriyaki sauce you use it for cooking
Yeah, I use it for dipping. I use most of these sauces for dipping and also like
Like mixing them in with like noodles
You know
Is
There a reason why you haven't used the timid size is it a respect thing is it laziness just laziness
It's just laziness. It's it's all like stuck together. It's not like an individual race ice pieces
And that's it. Yeah, thanks for listening
That's it
I'll move back to the chatting street screen
Oh
You can still see it
Yeah, that's it folks, um
I mean we'll still chat a little bit, but did you like did you like it? Did you like my room?
I hope you liked it
Most of them are good. Wait, so does that mean that some of the sauces are expired eyes
Wait, what?
Most of them are good. Does that mean some of the sauces? Well, yeah, some stuff is expired, but that's normal like
I lived with a mom that does not see expired as expired like she does not see expiry dates
So the fact that you know most of the stuff in my fridge is fine
um
That's that's that's progress. Okay
Like and even if the sauces are expired if they still taste good, they still taste good and I'll still use them. Okay. Okay. Thank you
Anyways chat
It's normal to keep running food in the in the bin with the food you intend to eat
Well, if it's just it's just a sauce sauces can last it's just a sauce
I didn't realize my fridge was the worst thing
Don't throw up my sauces. I use my I use my sauces you I'm glad I didn't show you my cupboards. Jesus christ. My cupboards are bad
As your big bro, we gotta clean this shit up. I think I read that already
Sauce is even when expired aren't really expired the dates on the packages are you aren't really regulated or even enforced by law
It's just a sauce as long as it tastes fine. Then
Then why can't I use it?
Yeah, leave the girl and her sauces alone
I saw nothing wrong with the fridge the freezer on the other hand the freezer was mostly empty
It's just it's just a messy fridge. That's all
And yeah
Like I don't I don't know a lot of the food I eat is not really like I don't like I keep it in my cupboards like
like tapaki and um
What other stuff do I keep in my cupboards? Um
Like seaweed
And uh noodles
The biology experiment pepper is not fine. It's just it's just a frozen pepper
It's just a frozen pepper
Who cares? I'm not gonna eat it. I don't plan on eating the pepper. Okay. I don't plan on eating it
Just don't get don't get sick for out of date sauces. I won't if the sauce tastes bad. I won't eat it
Get some penicillin for your sauce
Why keep the pepper? I'm lazy. It's just like I don't even
I don't see the pepper when I open my freezer. I don't see the pepper. Is that so bad
The pepper is not really in my field of vision most of the time
Like when I like I don't see the pep it's it's not in my field of vision. I just don't see it
Yeah, you're interrogating me about my fridge like I'm so sort of criminal
Like I'm going to jail for having some old sauces
Are you asian or do you just happen to eat a lot of asian food? I just eat a lot of asian food
I like asian food
like um
I just eat a lot of asian food and their sauces
Yeah
Asian food is probably like my favorite type of food. I was raised by a white mom discovering asian food was like amazing
like
Discovering asian food for the first time was like wow
A whole new door has opened for me and also like I'm a weeb. So of course I like asian food
I'm sure most of your fridge isn't even in your field of view. I wear glasses. It's in my field of view
Did you ever discover spices as a white girl? Yes, I have spices too
in my um
Like in my um
In my cupboards. I just didn't show you my cupboards and good thing too because you would roast the shadow of me for my cupboards
Because my cupboards have a lot of spices too
Oh
You can't wait for the wrestling match. I
Are we gonna have an actual wrestling wrestling match like maybe after we get
3d models
I'd totally do a wrestling match with strani after we get 3d models, but I feel like that would look weird
I feel like that would look good. No, I'm not showing you the cupboards. You're gonna roast me for my cupboards
I literally you I literally like okay. This is where the hoarder part comes out
You know the bts meal
That came out like
Freakin five years ago. I still have my bag in my cup from the bts meal
And also like
Like when I was at the asian grocery store, I found like
Like um sailor moon cans
soda cans to replace the four-year-old pepper
Thank you. Thank you
I found when I was at the asian grocery store one time I found um sailor moon themed soda cans and I I drank the soda and kept the cans in my
Cupboard yes, they're washed out. Yes. It doesn't have food in there, but I just kept it and I haven't really
Throwed it out. I don't I forget about it. I forget that it's there
Sailor moon is acceptable, but bts. I was a bts fan
Seriously, they'll put the bread either in the freezer or out, but if I put it in the freezer then I can't eat it and I don't really have a lot of
Like countertop space
I don't have open drinks. I have one open drink. I usually don't have open drinks
Sauses are just sauces though
She's gonna be streaming a year from now and someone's gonna randomly pop into the stream and ask a it is the is the pepper still there?
I guess maybe it might still be there. I don't know. I'm just lazy. I didn't think I'd be roasted for a single bell pepper
and sauces
They're just collectibles I eat that
I'm just getting roasted now. I really thought people would roast me for how cluttered my place is
Or like how it just doesn't really look like it fits together
Um, but instead I'm just getting roasted for my sauces and peppers
Thank you for becoming a member
A pepper emo no no you cannot remove the pepper it lives there now it's stuck to the freezer now
It's stuck to the freezer you cannot remove it. Okay, it I'm not gonna take it away from its home
Your place was really cute and cozy. I'm glad you actually liked it. I mean it is old lady, but like
And I like old lady stuff. It's like cozy. I will not take the pepper with me when I move no
Girlie pop outside an old lady inside. Yes
That's me. That's me
It's it's home is the trash can
Oh the pepper. No, it's home is my is my freezer
The pepper will the landlord can take care of the pepper when I leave
You should be real proud of it. Thank you. I don't know. I don't
Maybe I can show you a picture of how it used to look like. Oh, why do I have dms?
done and done, okay
Maybe I can log in I
Might be able to show you how it used to look like
Perhaps
It was bad
Hold on. Let me let me see if I can log into another account here
No, the pepper does not have a name
Oh
Sorry, I'm looking for like a picture. Uh, are you kidding me? I have to scroll. Okay, let me go on my phone
Do you want to name the pepper in my freezer you really want to name it?
Oh my god, sure we can we can vote on a name if you want
Oh
I think it's in my photo gallery
Uh, I should have a picture of it. Hold on. It's probably not going to be great quality because
There it is. Hold on. Let me just uh, fuck
You can kind of see like oh, but that's too clean. I have to show you a picture from when it was shitty
Oh, I have pictures of my first rats in my phone too
I didn't take a lot of pictures of it back then because obviously I was like this place kind of looks ugly
Hmm
You can see it in a lot of my old streams. I have I still have all of my old shorts that I used to make
saved to my phone whenever I like
Did um
Like the old streams from like years ago. It's kind of cringe to look back on it. I'm like ill
I was hella cringe. I still have like
My old prison project audition. That was bad. That was bad
And pictures of my old fish too
She was cute. I don't think I can find it
Oh, well
You I even have a dance cover that I made for I literally made an entire dance cover for an audition
Can you believe that?
That's cringe. Oh, let me look at it
Oh my god
Oh, I literally uh, I learned a whole dance because the um
The company was like, oh dancing is a skill we're looking for and I was like
That let me let me learn the dance
And so I learned an entire dance. I learned um
Oh my god, I was so cute. I had like bright pink and purple hair. I actually looked really cute
I'm not showing it to you though. It's cringe. Um
It was um
Fuck it was
Was was the kpop group
And
All that running
Sorry
Someone sent me that video in marshmallow once and for some reason my my um
My browser will not forget about it every time I go to youtube. I learned uh katalena by orange caramel. That's the dance I learned
But it was bad like I'm not a dancer
So it was it was bad. Okay, let's just say that it was really bad
It's a catchy song
I'm just going through my phone now and trying to find pictures not much
Oh
Why did it look better before oh because I had the smaller couch
Dance for us when you get 3d. No. Oh, it's so bad
Absolutely not
I
My dancing is not good. I thought I could pull it off just because it's I was like
Oh, I've I've danced before not professionally, but I've danced before so maybe I can dance for them, you know
If they're looking for dancing then
maybe maybe they'll be um
Impressed because I
You know, I doubt many people put a whole dance cover
in their audition
Anyways turns out uh, it is now years later. Obviously they rejected me is now years later and that company has um
Disbanded they went they went out of business. So
It's a good thing that they didn't grab me actually
It's a very good thing that they get they rejected me because they
Oh another business
And I really can't find like a single picture of my old apartment. I found really cute pictures of me though
And also my furry heart
Oh well
And also my rats I found a lot of cute pictures of my rats
Okay
Yeah, they went under it because they didn't have me
Disbanded like uh, they ran out they went out of business basically
Can we see the furry art no
There's something cathartic about seeing businesses that rejected you slash you stopped working for and they went under
Oh, it's so
Satisfying. Oh, I love to see it. It's happened multiple times now and I love to see it every single time it happens. I'm like
Take that
That's what you deserve
That's what you get
So, yeah
It's happened like three times now
Which is more than once
Don't a thumb go for a dance. I'm not good at it. Like I'm not good at dancing. I'm just I I uh
Like I just did it because I was like, ooh
They want people who dance and I've danced before
You know
It's so cathartic. It's so good
So satisfying
I get it's not revenge. It's not it's not particularly revenge, but it's more like
One I dodged a bullet and two like
I don't know how to describe it like yeah, that's what you get. I guess
Nothing brings me more joy to see them gone after all the lives they've destroyed
I mean, they didn't destroy my life my life by rejecting me
but
It just feels good because it's like
I know
It feels good. Okay, it feels good
Yeah, it's their fault
Hopefully vealer will stay up forever. Hopefully I don't know
I'm kidding. I
There's been no
No signs that it will go down anytime soon
I
Looked at my last company just now and found out they went under good good. Were they horrible corpos?
I will not slander any company on stream
I do not want to get sued by japanese companies that will sue you for saying anything bad about them
So
No comment
Yeah
As long as you and the other girls keep being awesome vealer will be around I hope so I hope so
Can you be sued by a company that doesn't exist anymore? Maybe
I don't know and I don't want to find out. I don't want to find out
I'm right now
Here I'm gonna type um I'm gonna type a text thing
Um
Um apartment tour is finished. We just chatting now
There
So that way when people come into the stream they um they know like
I'm I'm I'm done doing the apartment tour. There you go
If you're not physically in japan then the japanese company companies threats of lawsuits for defamation are empty
I just don't want to tell like
Not secrets, but like stuff that isn't known to the public I guess
My first job was a money laundering business at least the last year or two it was damn
It also reflects badly on you for japanese companies that do exist. That's true. That's true not that I aim to
join one, but like
I mean japanese companies already don't like us for the obvious reason
Japanese companies hate us
Specifically veeler there. They don't like us. Um
So yeah, not even like it's not even the towns that hate us. It's just
the companies
Yes, I'm staying classy
Um
Not at all enough. Yeah, yeah, yeah, not say so enough
Corporal say boo to the harlot company
They they just I don't I don't know why they um
They're not jealous. I think it's just like honestly, I don't know what it is
I guess they just don't want their talents to be seen as like
Lude or whores because a lot of
Japanese v tours in like the corporal sphere you're like supposed to be like really cutesy and pure I think
I think
Yeah, my oh she doesn't have a vagina
How dare you even imply that my oh she has a vagina and gets and gets um
I think of another way to say
It and gets a little bit corny sometimes. How dare you even imply that?
By streaming with of vtubers that are elude
And they don't poop either how dare they even make a poop joke. Don't they don't they know that girls don't poop or fart
Yeah
Yeah, it's it's influenced by the idol industry. So
That's why it's like that. That's why it's like that
um
So I understand why they don't want it to just with a 10 foot pole literally I can't even I shouldn't say that
How dare you imply my pure idol has thoughts and feelings and bodily functions literally
Now I'm just shitting on them. I'm sorry. I'm sorry if you feel that way, but also like
That's weird if you do
Payment process also pitch a fit if you do anything adult and it can make it hard to survive as a business without their support
That's true
but um
Just collabing with us doesn't do anything
For payment processors. I'm just I'm just like ranting that Japanese companies don't like us. That's all
That's all
I
That's how it goes. Yeah, I know
Idol culture is really cool, but also sucks at the same time. Yeah
I don't know they they do cool stuff like their performances are really cute
Like the girl groups are super cute. I like watching them perform in pretty dresses and stuff and act cutesy
but um
It can be a little bit crazy sometimes it can be a little bit crazy
um
Collabbing with you equals being aware of the concept of horny content which can make the payment processors angry
I think it's more it can make the fans angry than the payment processors
Payment processors are like, I don't know mastercard or visa
Visa isn't gonna be like, oh, what's that?
big company
ballo bive
Just collabed with vealer. Are you shitting me right now?
Cut any cut any any
Cut out any services we provide for them right at this moment. They played minecraft together
Are you kidding me? They played minecraft together?
Drop them drop them and and block their emails and and and block any um
Block any phone calls where we're not we're not touching these guys anywhere like
I don't I don't think that's it. I think it's it's more just the the the um
The like the executives have us of the companies have a stick up their butts
And they're worried about the fiend's reaction who also have a stick up their butts
No collabs with volvo live, I know
Volvo live, obviously, I don't think we'll collab with volvo
volop live
I was just using that as an example of a japanese company because it's a really big japanese company
But obviously I don't I'm not I'm not expecting that ever but it's just an example
That's all
Minecraft is a war crime with us. Of course. It's a war crime
Being in the same stream as us is a war crime
Liking and retweeting our tweets war crime
The moment any of them even like our tweets it's over she's become a whore and she belongs to the streets
And her pussy is loose
Because she liked imv's twitter twitter message
Sorry now now i'm just um exaggerating
But you know what I mean
There's an element of wanting to protect the talents. I think like they worry. Yeah the backlash. Yeah, I know it can
It can impact the creators. Yeah
Contraptions that spawn and kill monsters are pretty war crimey
And you will make a formal apology to us. Yeah, and we will suspend you for two weeks for that
I don't know how common suspensions are anymore
I feel like because people know what the know about them they're not as common
Unless it's like a really big company
I don't know
I guess I wouldn't know I guess I wouldn't know
Can it be an apology with the ukulele? No, you have to be on your knees begging and sobbing and crying and bowing over and over again
They do stealth ones. I know but like
Because people know about stealth ones. I feel like it doesn't happen as often. I don't know
Yeah, like I don't remember the last time I saw someone suspended or like oh guys. I'm going on a
Really last minute vacation for a week. Sorry you guys
you know
um
like
I don't know
Amy suspended until she removes the pepper from the fridge do it
Go tech go sans tronnie and marshmallow right now and tell her to suspend me until I put that until I sent her a picture
Of that pepper in the in the garbage can
Go ahead
Yeah, I have a health break kind of I mean
Yeah
I know health breaks can also just be like I'm tired of dealing with management. So I don't want to stream
Or just I'm tired of dealing with this company. So I don't want to stream. It could either be that or a suspension
um
But I can promise you that any health breaks we have had of healer are not suspensions
Oh, don't test this someone will do that. Go ahead. Just don't be mean to her about it. Be nice to her about it
I don't know what they're called but basically a big tower
Uh
Cernix
Thank you for becoming a member again. Oh my god
Cernix is one of my vtuber children. Cernix don't don't don't don't come to members asmr streams
Cernix
You're not ready you're not prepared for the members asmr stream as my child you should not be seeing that
As my child you should not be seeing that
Cernix gonna open mirrors to get flooded with messages about a random pepper. She's gonna be so confused
She already has members mirrors open. Doesn't she?
I thought she did
I can imagine what you'd call
What you y'all could even do to catch a suspension and fueler without being banned on a platform
Well, our suspensions are us being banned on the platform because we did we the platform hates us
Well, not hates us. We probably did something lewd. Um
Thank you for becoming a member
Um
But no, we don't
Cernix has said over and over that we don't do suspensions
Yeah
We don't we don't do them. So don't worry. The only time I'll be suspended is by youtube because I uh stepped on their toes
Um
And uploaded something kind of lewd speaking of kind of lewd. Um the newest video. I I wanted to have some sort of
Ear milleming, um
And and uh mimosa did send me audio of her literally like guzzling down on your ears
And I was like, I can't I I can't use it. So
Um, I still wanted to have something
And what I did instead was
Denputt taught me this trick I have these um fidget toys that are little worms
They're like little gelatinous fidget toy worms that you can like stretch and stuff
And I um covered them in lube
And then I rubbed them on the ears
Yeah, I rubbed like squishy lube dub worms on your ears and that's what it was
I feel like it's it's close enough, right?
I feel like it's close enough
Should we not use mim's current name?
I don't but
Sorry, does she not like it when we use that name? I don't know Rune. I say mim's because um
I tagged her as that in the video
But she goes by Rune
Reefling raid, hi reeflings. Hi
Welcome. Um, we already finished our apartment tour. So we're just talking now
But if you want to watch the apartment tour, you can just go back earlier in the stream
But hello, thank you for coming
Hope it doesn't get banned to me too. I don't think it's that bad
Um, what's the next patreon audio? That's a good question
I don't know
Maybe I can check
Congrats on 30k little sis love. Thank you, scrawny. Thank you
um
You
Strawny, what's my next patreon audio? I don't know. They're being updated in like 12 hours. Okay, there you go
Nobody knows yet
Emerus has a bell pepper in her freezer. Oh, you're tattling on me. You're tattling on me
It's not that bad
Isn't it like flat-chested? I don't know the order. I guess it's flat-chested friction
They're just mad that I have a four-year-old bell pepper in my freezer. That's all
I'm not I don't play on eating it. I just have it in the freezer and they want me to throw it out and that's all
It's not that bad. They're overreacting. You guys are being dramatic right now
Seatting absolutely seething
Furiously typing on your keyboard right now while your while your fingers are shaking. Let me get rid of the fucking bell pepper
I don't use the last tenant's eyes. It's just there. It's just there. It's just sitting there at the back of my freezer
I don't use it
Anyways
Now that's stuck in my head what day is it today?
Do you guys want to um
Do you want to plan not next week but the week after stream?
Amy I will pay you $50 to go throw the bell the pepper out right now
Make it a hundred and I'll do it. In fact, I'll take a picture of the pepper in the in the garbage
Otherwise that pepper is staying in my fridge
Um
I wouldn't put anything near that thing out of fear. It's just
Hey guys, it's so dramatic. It's just a pepper. Okay, let's um plan not next week but the week after I want to plan that together
um, so next week I have
Monday wizard 101, uh, Wednesday little nightmares two
Friday amnesia member stream. Um, and then saturday is martrain
Are you gay? Why are you? Oh my god
Something original tipped $100. Clean your fridge. You're mullin
Okay, I'll go throw out the bell pepper
Man
I'll be back. Okay, I'll be back with a picture of the bell pepper in the garbage
Oh
Yeah
I'm back
I put I just I went to pee and fill up my water bottle too
But I I put the I put the pepper in the fridge. I mean in the fridge
I moved the pepper from the freezer to the fridge. There you go
No, I'm put the pepper in the garbage and I'll take a picture for you
Oh
This is a chat that you dare to tip for a peek at your chest
What did you think was gonna happen? Don't challenge pin pals. They are a rowdy bunch
But it's $100 for
for a picture of a pepper in a garbage can like
I don't know
It's so big. Sorry
Um
There it is
Here it is
The most hated fucking pepper in the world there has never been a more hated pepper
Because no one gives a fuck about peppers than this one singular pepper simply because it is old
Simply because it is a hag
This is ageism at its finest and it's in the trash now
You think I I went and just ai generated a pepper in a garbage can
I
Look how she massacred our boy you asked me to put the pepper in the garbage
I won't put it back in the fridge. It belongs in the garbage now
He was so he was so young
Only lived to four years old. He had so much potential
He could have gotten moldy
He could have he could have been planted
In the ground and grown seeds and grown more peppers
But now he's just being sent off to the gulag
To death to be beheaded and then thrown
thrown away
In a in a was it called trash facility?
It's not photoshopped. Who do you mean?
It's in the trash. I literally just went in the trash right now
I don't know why you guys don't trust me
I'm not putting it back now. I'm not that disgusting. I'm not my mom
My mom would see this perfectly beautiful pepper in the trash and take it and put it back in the freezer. That's for sure
But I'm not her. I will break the cycle
anyways
That's wrong
I'm not I'm not going back to make a video for the pepper in the trash
I'm so sad that you don't trust me that much. Okay. Anyways, moving on. Um, so that's next week scheduled
Monday wizard one-on-one Wednesday little nightmares Friday amnesia
um Saturday ASMR train
um
But I want to I want to because you guys all fuck
Hold on. I need to I need to log back into EME on discord
Thank you for the funds for a new pepper. I don't even like peppers that much. That's why I never really ate it
Or is it just kind of meh? I'm okay with them, I guess
Now the question is do I have the password for
My login
No, I don't
Okay, well, I'm pretty sure we're gonna continue. Um, uh
On that Monday, uh, we're gonna continue. Wait, can I not show everyone else's schedules? Oh, I can oh, I can turn them off
Oh, that's perfect for me. Okay there. So that way I can show you this and um
Yeah
Here there we go
I
Can show you
this
And that way we can make our schedules together and ignore how it says Toronto. That's just the time zone
I don't live in Toronto. Some people will see that and be like, we found Debbie's location
Doxxed
It's just the time zone chill out. Anyways, um
Yeah, so this is the schedule for next week, but let's do the week after together. So this one, um
It's gonna be at the usual time
But this one we're doing um chain together again
With the
Oh, you can even see what I'm typing
There we go
Location detected
I can tell you don't live there because you pronounce the second T
Do people don't pronounce it like Toronto. I say Toronto people say Toronto Toronto
Toronto
Um, let me chain together again with um
Chibi
I think this might be changed, but I think it's it's pretty solid. Um
We're playing it again because we had a fun. I love those girls
Uh, yep. Anyways, you guys wanted a member stream, right? Can you do a Toronto accent? No
I don't know how I'm not good at accents in general. They're then British. Oh, let me bring myself on top of this
Um
Okay, you guys wanted a witchcraft stream
Do you want to do a member's witchcraft stream on on wednesday?
Okay
Is that okay for you
Your emoto accent is good. It's not an accent
Yes, okay glad I could do that and then let's play let's play um
You can be reading tears we can do it all we can make some some spell bottles and we can read tears
Together we can do both
Um
You wanna play five minutes of freddy's I wanted to do I could believe forgot what I was gonna do. Oh ring fit
What's that game called?
ring fit adventure
one
I wanted to play that because I saw stradis been playing it. I want to play it
Called ring fit adventure. Yeah, let's play that
And I'll do I'll do the the heartbeat thingy too during it ring fit adventure
I've been wanting to do that
Okay, what else do you want me to do?
I want to do stuff that you want what is ring fit wise with a strike on your channel
Oh, are they gonna strike me for fucking panting?
Are they gonna strike me for panting?
I won't be like up in the mic like like I'll be like farther away because I'll be like jumping around
Hmm, okay, it might be an archive then
Sorry can't risk it
I'll be far away from the mic. I won't be all up in the mic. I'll be standing up further, but
You're still gonna hear me like pants because obviously it's a tiring game
I
Mom, uh, mom it also has a strike and also did it without problem. I know but I don't want to risk it
Also, does she have a strike? I thought she just had a warning
I don't know
Maybe she does have a strike. I don't know
I don't want to risk it
She has a warning. I have a strike. She has a warning a strike is worse than a warning
So, yeah, anyways
Um, let's do one more stream. What do you want to do?
Maybe I could do some sort of hand cam. I have oh
um
I have in my desk right now. I never built it
I have a nano blocks a nano block. Um
Thingy of Kirby we can build that together
Do you want that?
Due to youtube thinking rat breathing
Offering lego it says the original microsoft microsoft microsized building blocks. I don't know. I think it's cute to build together
I only have one though. Maybe we can build lego's afterwards too if I build it too quickly because I think
I don't know. It looks kind of simple
What are nano blocks tism lego's
They're um, they're just like
Figures figurines here. I can probably show you what I have
I've just had in my desk for a while
Um Kirby
Oh, I have to take a screenshot
I
Want it oh there we go
Sorry, I had to take a screenshot of the nano blocks
This is what I have this is what nano blocks are cute right
It looks really cute. I have some in my room already
What are your thoughts on playdoh very yummy snack
Yeah, it's Kirby
So I can build this it's very tiny it's very small but it's cute
Um
And it'll be at the usual stream time
There yay are these good for you
If you want to avoid getting bonks do naked you'll go you know
Oh
Absolutely not
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped five dollars. I just wanted to say that we didn't have an rp stream in quite a while
You want a roleplay stream like an asmr roleplay stream?
Hmm
And I'm bad at controlling myself during those I tend to say stuff stuffy stuff and then get banned
Both my strike and my um
And my warning were first from streams
Are you doing a 35k or 40k celebration? No
I um, I'm growing a little too fast. I don't have time to do every single celebration
Um, but I appreciate like people joining and and subscribing and helping me grow, but it's like
I think I should space out the um
Celebrations a little more, you know, I even asked Manes on like can you stop can you stop posting like um
congratulation messages for when I reach milestones because um
It's getting a little bit too often
And I don't want the vlore twitter to just be like congratulations to me on reaching 50k subscribers
Congratulations to me on reaching 40k subscribers like
It's enough. Thank you
Yeah, I'm a grower
I thought we weren't doing those until I kind of want to like my I think my most two popular streams have been asmr streams
I don't really want to do five streams in a week. I I like spacing streams out like this. Um, it's like
The best for my mental health as weak as that sounds, but I'm I'm not strawny and I'm not sheebie
Um, I can't stream every day. It kills me which just sucks because I like spending time with you, but I just I get so
Like drained it's sad, but I just get drained in general. That's why I don't leave my house
Literally like going to the grocery store kills me so um
Um
One every other day and then here I'll do um the monday after or wait
Oh, wait, hold on. I might have plans on
I might have plans this day. Hold on. Hold on. I need to check something. I realize I might have plans for that day
I
No, we're good. Sorry never mind. That's the wrong weekend
Here we can do um
An asmr stream here and plus I post asmr videos
So that kind of makes up for the lack of asmr streams, but I don't know what kind of asmr stream would you want?
I
I'm really bad at role playing could it be a brosley stream if you don't want to risk it even if it's just safer work
Brosy streams are even more draining than regular streams if you can
Imagine what is this gaming rats hand cam asmr? What what do you want me to do?
Rats don't listen to me. I can't just like put my rat in front of the camera and like pet its belly for like two hours
Like they're not gonna stay in front of the camera. They that they they they fidget and they run and they move around
so
Something lewd we just had the brosley stream
Training on brosley has a double me
He can shows me great. You want to do like bj asmr?
There's there's there is one asmr. I really wanted to make it was like taking a bath with me asmr
Cuz strani did that too, right?
Oh, this is so gonna get big but bonked
No, I'll be say so my other my other bat bathing asmr was cute. It was just like a son of date, but
I'll so I'll stay I'll I'll be uh
Control yourself and we don't say anything
Right there we have a good amount of
A good amount of streams
Thank you for the three dollars
Please don't strain yourself your mental health health is important as well as your physical as much as I like
To see more in my little sister um who I love very much. I want her to be in the best health
Proud of you and we'll keep supporting you. Thank you
I feel bad. I feel like I'm the I sometimes I feel like I'm the one who streams the least in velour
But I try to make up for it by like posting other content too
um
But yeah, yeah
We you might be able to but can we be say so knowing you're in a bath
Probably not
How about I just turn chat off for that stream because every time I do an asmr stream
People who get like really really lewd and it's like I bounce off of people's energy
So then I start to get lewd and then it's like fuck
I can't I can't do that. I have bonk myself
I
There's plenty of your content. Okay, good
Never feel bad about your stamina stamina we understand. Oh, thank you. I'm a quick shot
You
Work the smartest for sure streaming is for connection and vods are for growing vods are not for growing at all
Vods can be for growing but they have to be really specific vods
and um, I don't always want to do asmr vods back to back to back
so um
Shorts and videos are for growth for sure. Those are what um lead to the most growth
Please take time for yourself. You're so nice
Amy I want your like asmr not here but a video or an audio on which the main triggers you're liking
I could probably do that on rosalie
I could probably
I wanted to play pickman pickman was another game I wanted to play because I saw strani play pickman
We're playing pickman together
I might have to get it for the Wii U
All of my controllers even the new fucking I hate I hate switches so much for this even my new
Nintendo switch controllers have janky joy cons
And I have trouble playing pickman because of that. So I might have to get pickman for the Wii U and play that instead
But I really like yeah, I own a Wii U. I've had it since like 2014
Maybe not 2014. Maybe like 2016. I've had it for a long time
But yeah strani raged that pickman. I'll just cry at pickman and also get scared. I'm kind of scared of pickman bosses
It's a little clunky be warned. I know
Can use a pro controller. I do use a pro controller and it still fucking sucks
Yeah
It me is one of the seven Wii U owners. I am
But I like Wii U's because I can play Wii U games and Wii games on it, you know
Get pickman 3 there's no time limit
We will see
Anyways on the 25th of september we're playing pickman
Yeah
Because I always think like oh, I like that game we should play that game together and then I never do it
And instead I do some random like hand cam stream
But with the Wii you can play Wii games and gamecube games on it, which is way better
But I don't play gamecube games
I have no
I have no nostalgia for
Gamecube games
unfortunately
um
I have a ds that can play uh
Gameboy games I think
You're missing out the gamecube has some real classics. Okay, but they're classics for you
They're classics for you to me. They're not classics
You know
They're not classics for me because I haven't played them and I don't know about them
Once they're Nintendo DS stream, oh you want a Nintendo DS stream
Should I play like some hella niche Nintendo DS games?
Is that what you want
We can play um
The problem is if I play a hella niche a hella niche Nintendo DS game, um
Then I don't know if I can even emulate them like
Will people have it on an emulator? I don't even know how emulators work to be honest
What's a classic for emmy
Nintendogs do you want to play nintendogs?
That's not niche. I have more niche ones, but I feel like
most ds games
I know I have like fucking
George of the jungle the ds game. Do you want to play that?
Like that's what I mean by hella niche
That's what I have like I have um
I don't even know
Like I have random games that don't even have English titles on them
I don't I
Let's just say that
No, I'm not gonna tell you where I got them from
I think I have that game
I have like what's it called princess and the frog the ds game
That's what I have
Okay, we can try I'll try I'll do a stream on the 27th of september
Where we just play niche
ds games
from
my childhood
There that's what we'll do
I might have to do a hand cam for that if I can't figure out how to use an emulator
But we'll play some niche ds games
Amy's family outside of Canada coming in clutch with the pirated games. No, no, they're not pirated
Like they're they're official
But I don't know what they're officially for
If that makes sense
See if they held up over time
They absolutely did not hold up over time because they were bad in the first place
I have like zuzu pets the ds game
You know
No, I've never pirated any ds games for real
My ds's are all 100 not hacked because I was a child and I didn't know how to hack them
You know
I don't know if I can still hack them. Can I I don't know but I'm not going to
Like I I yeah, I'm not going to
Because I like them and I don't want to break them. I don't want to break them
If you emulate your pirating. Oh, yeah, I know that but it's I don't know. I feel like it's not bad to pirate Nintendo
So I don't care
I don't care I've pirated worse
Let's just say that I've pirated much worse than Nintendo
It is morally correct to pirate Nintendo. You should pirate Nintendo
Especially older Nintendo, yeah
Like where else am I going to find um
Hold on I'm trying to think of the the ds game I got
Or I can't even think of where else are you going to find Guardians of Goho the ds game
Nowhere you either pirate it or go on ebay and pay like I don't know a hundred dollars for a shitty version of it
That's fake. I don't know actually
Is it on ebay?
It
Is on ebay and you gotta pay 20 dollars for it
It's actually a really good game and the graphics are actually really good. I'm not gonna lie
First time the graphics are amazing. It's my favorite game. It's my favorite game
I've played a lot
um
Yeah
If buying isn't owning privacy isn't stealing oh piracy isn't stealing. I mean you you can
Own the game cartridges in that case you do own it, but yeah, I know what you mean
Where else am I gonna find hello kitty birthday party
Birthday, I don't know birthday party adventures for the Nintendo DS
I'm not gonna pay 70 dollars for it
I have I think
I've paid a lot for niche hello kitty games. Let's just say that
Thank you for becoming a member
It means promoting DS graphics. No, but actually it looks good for a d like like let me show you
This is a little bit like
No one cares about this other than me
Like I know no one cares about this
But for a DS game the graphics are good. Okay
Let me just show you. Oops. I wrote guardians of the galaxy
Like no one cares about this movie. It was my favorite fucking movie as a child every time I talked to it
Talked to it like talked about it to my friends. They were like
I don't know what you're talking about and I don't care, but to me
It was my shit, dude
It was my shit. I loved it. Look at this. Oh, that's for xbox 360. Oh
There's an I don't have an xbox
Come on
Oh, that's why it looks so good because it's for xbox 360
Um
This looks like the
Nintendo Wii video
I'm looking for the DS version
Listen, all I remember is that it looked good
This looks like the DS version
Here
It's a shitty screenshot because you don't see much, but I'm telling you
I'm telling you right now
Look
This is good for a DS game. Obviously. It's blurry before a DS game. Okay. This is good. This is good
Look at that. That's amazing. That's amazing for DS. They really did a lot
Anyways, um, I love the owl movie. I'm glad I have more owl autists in chat
Right, right. What are we looking at a screenshot from the DS game?
For DS, this is good and I don't know how they even managed to do this
But for DS, it looks good
Because a lot of DS games looks like shit
I know I know I know not many people care about it, but I care
I wanted more album war movies. I wanted more movies too. I started reading the book as an adult then I got bored
But I really liked the movie. It was so good
And even the movie even the graphics of the movie are like really really beautiful too. I think they're beautiful
I don't know
Is my favorite movie
Um, I have not played marvel's rise of the imperfects. No
Book series was great. I'm sure it was
Do we read the books or watch the movie? There's only one movie. Um
I would recommend probably reading the books and then watching the movie
But the book obviously it's a movie so it cuts out a lot of stuff from the book
Um, but they're both really good
We had owls of gujul and rango relatively close to each other. It feels like we got no movies like that anymore trill
Yeah
Imagine if they made movies of the warriors books
That would have been really popular actually
I don't know why they didn't
Warriors was really really popular
Why did they never make a uh a warriors book?
I would have I would have ate that shit up. You know what I was really excited for
Once again a book that no one knows about
But my favorite book series as a child. I didn't read no harry poa. I didn't read no pussie jackson
You know what I read? I found a random dragon book in the um
Library of my school when I was in like
Sixth grade and ever since then I've been obsessed with the book series
And I've wanted a movie or show made out of it and it was um
It was wings of fire that was my favorite series
No, it wasn't aragon. It was wings of fire
um
I I don't think there's been more but like I've been um
What's it called
Like in in phases I would go in and out of phases of keeping up with the book series
I'm not sure if it had if it ended yet, but if it did end it's like recently ended and it's been going on for a really long time
um
It was good I couldn't remember the name of that I couldn't remember the name of that for nothing. Yeah
I
Loved it. It was my favorite book series
And I I so wanted them to have a movie
I was I needed the movie so bad, but I don't I think it's done
I think it's done. Let me just see
Come on, there's 15 books
Is there gonna be a book 16?
Wait, what?
Hey, there's a book 16. Wait, hold on. I'm confused. Why does it only show 15 books on the website?
How many is there gonna be new books? I've only read up to the b1
I've only read up to the b1. Um
The hive queen that's what I've read up to
And I started poison jungle, but I didn't finish it
I
Didn't Netflix announced an adaptation for that like last year. It was years ago and it got canceled
And I was so mad. I was I was freaking out. I was going crazy. I was crying tears of joy
I was like finally finally we get a crumb of something cool and then they canceled it
They canceled it which is fine because I'm guessing they would have censored it for the show
That book was a little bit strange in the sense where it was it seemed like it was marketed to children
Um, it seemed like it was marketed to children. But for some reason there was like really gory scenes
in that book
That were like kind of too gory for children
um
So it wasn't woke enough is my guess the series is very woke actually
The series is pretty woke. There's like gay dragons
There's gay dragons. It's very woke
Which is sweaty
But yeah
Um, the last one I read was the ice dragon queens if I'm ice dragon queens
Are you talking about winter training?
My favorite was definitely unwind. I've never heard of unwind
Gay dragons you say
Oh the kids that's not for the kids don't show the kids the gay dragons
They're gonna hate it. Wasn't there like throw slitting and dismemberment in those? Yeah
Yeah, that's why I like them. I thought it was cool
I had a huge crush on
Hold on. Let me just make sure I'm saying his name, right?
No
I forgot his name. I can't believe I forgot the name of my biggest crush that dark stalker dark stalker is like one of the
One of the antagonists in the books and I was I that was my childhood crush
I was I didn't care about like any of the
I didn't care about any celebrities or cartoon characters. I had a crush on a on a book dragon
I thought it was so hot
Are these dragons bad? Oh, they're very bad
These are very very bad dragons
They're even in the bad dragon catalog. You should go check it out
Sounds like a childhood crush name
Listen, they had really cringe names like all the dragons had like
Warrior cats level cringe names, you know
So, yeah, it's a cringe name, but he was my favorite
Why are all your favorites called edgy stuff like dark stalker twilight of this? I don't know
I don't know. I don't know my second favorite was just called sunny though
So it's not that crazy
You're so real for that. I mean, thank you. Thank you
Chuny maxing wait
Oh
The witch girl is edgy imagine it's not really edgy to like him
Edge chronicles no, I didn't read a lot of series growing up
I didn't watch some movie called chronicles something
No, I didn't read edge chronicles
But I did watch
What did I watch
I
Watched the movie spider wick chronicles. I thought that was good. I enjoyed that movie
I was really really scared of like the goblins in that movie that was terrifying
I watched I watched spider wick. I actually never watched chronicles of narnia. No
Nope
Yeah, I was terrified of spider wick chronicles
Ew looking back at pictures of that movie. It's so ugly
another one I watched was um
What was it called this one's really old I think some of you will remember this because you're old
Oh, let me try to remember it
Every time every time I try to remember it was like about a boat
Not about a boat, but it one of the main plot lines was about a boat
um
It was like a magical boat, maybe
Can you recommend old movies about a boat that had a boat in it?
And I watched it as a kid. No, it was like a huge boat like a pirate boat
um
No, not life of pie. I'm not that young
No, not tight. Come on guys. It was like a it was like a mystical magical boat and had fairy creatures
in it and I had like
um
No, not come on
It's a niche. It's a niche one. It's a niche one. Um
Peter Pan. Oh my god. Look. No, it's a really
Noah's Ark
Junie to Atlantis. No, it wasn't animated. Is that one animated?
What is that?
No, no, no, it wasn't animated. It was live action. Um
Come on. It's not Gulliver's Travels. Um
One time I literally typed in the description and not Pirates of the Caribbean, not the Odyssey. No
If I had to explain it, it was like
From what I remember it was a story about a dad and two daughters
And I think one day like
One night their home got like raided by like ugly fucking
big-ass like
goblin guys
I don't know what to describe them. They're really ugly and um
I don't know what they did. Maybe they kidnapped one of the daughters or something
and brought
Brought her like, I don't know what they did or maybe they kidnapped their mom. I don't know
But they got on some boat and there was a Minotaur guy on the boat too. I think he was really ugly too
Was it NSFW? No
It was a children's movie. Um
And um
Gilligan's Island, no
Man now I need to know
No, it wasn't Gilligan's Island. It was like really mystical and magical. Um, and there was one scene where like they found a
They found like a desert and there was like a
There was like an underground maze in the desert. It was not Percy Jackson. Oh my god voyage of the unicorn. I think that might be it
It was voyage of the unicorn
That's what it was. I watched that. Oh my god
That scared the shit out of me. Is it a show?
Two hours and 15 minutes
This isn't a show
So I got it. Yeah, we found it was a monsters ink. Oh my god
Thank you. Thank you made for tv movie. It's
We should watch voyage of the unicorn together. It's crazy. It's whack
It's scary. It's weird, but I really like it. I really liked it as a kid
I thought the fairies were super super pretty and beautiful like the costuming for that movie is really really pretty
I googled children's movie with a boat and minotaur and voyage of the unicorn show came up. Yeah
Yeah, that's probably what I googled before too, but I I couldn't quite get it
But yeah, that's what I watched as no one here watched it
seriously
How many people how many people in chat have watched it?
Is it Canadian? I have no clue
Nope. Nope. Nope. Never. No. No
Holy crap, not a single person in chat has watched it
I might have seen that when I was a kid. Yeah, when when was it from?
It's only from 2001
Never heard of it. Holy crap. Okay
Okay, we'll watch voyage of the unicorn together. We'll watch voyage of the unicorn together
Let me put that on the schedule. I got it. I got to introduce you to it
It may be the old one. No, no, I didn't watch it in 2001
No
The one watch along I do is for of some niche movie that no one even knows about
I
Was a really manly man couldn't watch no unicorn movie. It wasn't really a like it wasn't a girly movie in the slightest
It's just called voyage of the unicorn. It was um
It was a pretty like
I don't know if it was children friendly, but like it was it was not a girly movie in the slightest
um, it had a lot of cool
You know cool epic scenes
And like fighting scenes and stuff
Amy voyage
Oh, shit, I don't have a member stream
For that week
Okay, what do you want to be the member stream the asmr
The pikmin the niche ds games or voyage of the unicorn because I want to do one
I want to do one member stream a week
Which one do you want to be the members asmr?
Your little sister force you to watch your favorite childhood movies. It's not gonna feel like a childhood movie because it's an old movie
Asmr asmr asmr. Okay. I'm mostly seeing asmr. So asmr will be the member stream the bathing
um
I just feel like watch alongs aren't really members
Like unless you specifically want it, I feel like I usually wouldn't do a watch along for a member stream, you know
Voyage of the unicorn is free to watch on youtube. Hey, that's perfect. That's perfect
So members only will be the
Beating with your little sister asmr. I might um, it's very it's very highly likely that I make that into an actual video as well
But that will probably be like scripted and have like some triggers in it. Maybe so
But as a stream we'll make that one members only
And then on the 29th
Plating three weeks ahead we'll do a voyage of the unicorn watch along
Free with ads got installed at ad blocker
The day I install an ad blocker is the day you finally mind broken me
Okay, I'm not broken yet
You have to do something
Really really extreme for me to install an ad blocker
Okay
Voyage of the unicorn
Watch along
Anyways, um, do you want to have a fansly stream one of these two? I mean brosly
Bros, do you do what? What are those two one of these days? Maybe at the end of the month near near the end of the month more
Um
I'm gonna plan it in september because I do want to I do want to go somewhere one of these days
If you're up for it
Um
Should I put it on the calendar or should we just choose a day?
I'll just like tweet out a day and like you can remind me and maro's okay
Remind me and maro's because oh wow, uh tits on twitter. Holy crap. Oh shit
Oh, shit. I'm not logged into my home. I'm not like to my NSFW account
Oh
I just got a I just got a little bit of an update for the
For one side of the body pillow. Would you like to see it?
Would you like to see the updated image?
Well, I have to take a screenshot of it again. It's only one side. I'm gonna have two sides
I'll show you a little photo of
Of the body pillow
I don't know when it'll be done, but
The artist seems to be making progress, which I appreciate because I'm I'm bad as an artist and I don't make a lot of progress on comms
That's why I don't make a that's why I don't have a lot of comms because I don't make progress on them
Here's the thighs
Eyes
Will I have an NSFW side? Yes, this is the safer work side though
Um, what was I gonna do? Oh, yeah, I was gonna tweet out a date for brosley now
Now
Would you prefer
Would you prefer um
A weekday or a weekend
I'm just like scheduling things with you now. I'm just working with you. You're helping me do my job right now
I mean it's helpful because sometimes I don't know what to do on stream
Um
A weekend weekend weekday weekend weekend weekend weekend weekend weekend, okay
Uh, will it be later at night again? It really depends on the day
Um, if it's a hot day, then it'll have to be moved to later at night if it's not a hot day, then no
Either is fine. Want to pull it? Okay, I'll pull it
We'll pull it
Thanks for helping me do my job
I'll start a poll
What type of day
Wait, hold on. Maybe I can weekday
I'll write like Saturdays
Saturday like a Saturday
a Saturday a sunday
There's your poll shoes shoes wisely
Friday's cool too. Okay. Okay. Okay. I should have added Friday as an option then
I can't okay. It seems like Saturday's winning
We'll do it on a Saturday then
You make it a members only poll as a non-member. I shouldn't have a say in that compared to your regulars
But it's gonna be a public stream
So it doesn't matter
You can be there
So yeah, we can be there
It won't be something crazy. Oh wait. We actually know it's not gonna be a public stream
Oh, it's gonna be members. Oh
Sorry, sorry
You're right. I don't think I can make a poll members only unfortunately though. No
I cannot make a poll members only for my what I can tell you're right. Sorry. I forgot. It's not gonna be it's not gonna be free
regard, um
Okay, well Saturdays probably makes sense. So let's do it
Let's do
Do one more won't fall. No, it's okay
It's okay. It's okay. Strani has
Was it in a members only stream?
Because I don't know how to do a members only poll
Uh
Let's do it on the 14th Saturday the 14th. How about that?
I'm just gonna tweet it out. Okay, and you remember you remember for me. Okay. Okay. Thank you
Today's the sixth holy shit today's the sixth today's already the sixth
How could I forget? Yeah next week
Okay, I'm gonna tweet though
So it's gonna be members only
Or subscribers I guess on brosley is that what it's called subscribers
Subscribers I can't even oh there it is
Yeah subscribers, that's what it's called
Yeah, I'll call it members only
On
The 14th it's gonna be you know what let's make it let's make it late again because I stream I stream already on that day
Um, so we'll make it at the same time as last time. Is that okay? I already stream on that day
So you'll have two streams in one day, you know
Subscriblers
The members tab has a locked poll function the members tab
On the members tab on youtube that's like the community tab, right?
Okay
Sorry, I'm tweeting it out
September 14th at 10
Edity
Yeah, you can catch the vlog too
You don't have enough grace versus members who just screwed the poll so just do Saturday. Yes 14th is Saturday. Yeah
One tab over community is member I see okay next time I'll do that. Sorry
um
10 p.m
Okay, we did it. Yay. We scheduled stuff for me for my job
Thank you. Thank you. Now I know when stuff is
Do you want me to show you the whole thing
This is the whole thing
Here's the whole month
Of september, right? Yeah
Here's the whole month of september
Or you just screen shot if you want now, you know the whole month of september is uh
The streams other than collabs collabs are usually last-minute stuff, but this is without collabs. There you go
Yay
You wanted to do a scheduling stream. Yeah, but more like scheduling for my personal life not like scheduling for content
You know
But here it is. Wow
Yippie. Sorry. I should stop moving around
So you can actually see it. Okay
There it is. Okay
Just tweet that calendar now
And uh, I'll I'll post the schedules every wait, did I yeah, I made the um, I'll post the schedules every week still
I'll still post it every week
Don't you worry. Anyways, I should go I should dip
Um
Let's see who's live Maeve is live
And out of all of the vtubers I follow. She's the only one that's like damn it. I need to follow more vtubers
I
Was up in 10 minutes. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Where's all this stream?
There she is
What's she doing?
Oh smash your pass for league of legends
Oh nice. Okay. I'll I'll dump you in in there
Manus Mamaki
Would menace be okay with me
I'll subscribe to her
You
No, I'm not dumping you I'm dumping you in a zero stream
I am picking you up and plopping you down in a zero stream. That's all I mean
I'm not actually dumping you
Um
Is your
I
There it is
Okay
She's associated with to any cancel that vtuber
I mean some people just don't want to associate themselves with me, which is fine. So that's why I don't really
Um raid too many new people
Because I don't want to step on any toes
I don't want to make anyone feel uncomfortable
Uh and then I should probably
Um
Copy her link too
Because youtube's been really bad lately and it's just they just haven't been
Hmm like redirects just haven't been working sometimes. So anyways, I'll see you
Sunday
What is it?
Sunday, I'll see you sunday
Um, we'll play piano together
Thanks for chilling with me. I made the stream like one hour longer than I usually do. Look at me go
I'm slowly becoming an endurance streamer
I already forgot the calendar me too, but I think I'll see you sunday. Um
Uh, yeah
Thanks for joining me today
Thanks for I guess convincing me to throw out my beloved bell pepper
That bell pepper has been through thick and thin with me and you made me throw it in the trash
As if it were trash
Uh, anyways, okay. Have a good night. Enjoy your azura's stream. I love you
Bye. Bye. You know what? I haven't seen it in a long time. Bye oni chan
Bye. Bye. Have a good night
You